so the classic example of a brand that
did very very well was J&J back I
believe in the 70s where there was a
tylenol scare and they pulled lots of
product off the shelf actions speak
louder than anything that you can do or
say and marketing so when we talk about
marketing wanting to talk about actions
and BP is challenged at this moment in
time and probably will be continued to
be challenged but no amount of marketing
no amount of ads they have in the New
York Times or commercials that they put
out there are really going to help them
until their actions are speaking louder
than their words and they stop the leak
and then they do the cleanup and I think
then they would be able to revive
themselves I believe when brands are
challenged they can't talk about things
they need to act very quickly and their
actions will allow them then to rise
again and actually could put them in a
better position than they were sometimes
before you can sometimes turn and lemon
into lemonade in these situations
I think the best thing that the BP
organization can do right now is really
from a public relations standpoint is to
inform the public about what they're
doing and how they're doing it any
actions that they're going through and
then the process they're going through
to establish and who they're bringing in
to help them they shouldn't try to
handle this on on their own right now
they should get citizen communities
involved they should take
recommendations from people about what
they should be doing or shouldn't they
be doing and they should bring that into
their plan to create that we're all in
this together to solve this awful
disaster that's happening in the Gulf of
Mexico right now I think as the plan
starts to execute which it is and
they're starting to siphon off some oil
now and they start to make progress once
it seems as though they have turned the
corner I think then they can open up the
marketing speak again about how BP is
helping to change the environment etc
etc